[Applaudissements]
boulevard Raspail dans le sixième ce
soir Nerita est chargé d'accueillir les
invités d'une soirée pas comme les
autres
pour nous c'est très important parce que
le Kosovo c'est un état
il y a eu l'indépendance et voilà ils
vont venir tout les pays qui sont
reconnus le Kosovo mérita est étudiante
à Paris le Kosovo c'est sa terre natale
en 99 elle a fui la guerre qui durant
des mois à placer sa région au centre du
monde depuis deux ans sa région est
devenue un pays un anniversaire que
célèbre la nouvelle ambassade du Kosovo
dans ce palace parisien
ils sont là
ambassadeur de Panama et Madame
[Musique]
Monsieur le Conseiller de l'Ambassade
des États-Unis
son excellence l'ambassadeur
d'Afghanistan
[Rires]
[Musique]
ber qui est un peu chez lui ce soir car
le Kosovo indépendant c'est avant tout
une victoire de l'Albanie arrachée à la
Serbie l'Albanie principalement
musulmane la Serbie orthodoxe qui depuis
des siècles se disputent un territoire à
peine plus grand que la Corse après la
guerre l'OTAN place la région sous
protectorat en 2008 le Kosovo peuplé à
90% d'Albanais se proclame indépendant
aujourd'hui seul un tiers des pays de
l'ONU dont la France a reconnu le
nouveau-né
cette réception c'est de voir quelles
sont les amis qui viennent qui
reconnaissent le Kosovo l'indépendance
de notre pays marquons la fin du
processus de la dissolution dans l'hélie
apparaît comme un facteur indispensable
de la paix et de la stabilité dans la
région et c'est la meilleure réponse aux
politiques de haine et d'exclusion
une petite soixantaine de pays ont
reconnu aujourd'hui ce Kosovo
indépendant sur les 190 que compte l'ONU
malheureusement
la République française a reconnu
l'indépendance du Kosovo
à la même heure au pied de l'ambassade
kosovar déserte et gardé par les CRS on
célèbre cet anniversaire outrement
[Musique]
on trouve là des militants français
d'extrême droite pas franchement proche
des Albanais et qui tentent de récupérer
la cause mais aussi bien sûr des Serbes
comme pré drague
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux jours plus tard pré drague et ses
deux amis se retrouvent dans le 18e au
bout de la rue Simplon il y a l'église
orthodoxe c'est un peu le QG des serres
de Paris rendez-vous au café juste avant
la messe
quoi
du conflit mais ses souvenirs sont
intacts
c'est un vrai traumatisme
c'est déjà bien qu'on soit en vie moi
j'étais un enfant
et les balles fusées de partout
devant l'église pas facile de parler du
Kosovo avec les anciens très peu ici en
sont originaires mais le sujet les prend
aux tripes
il y avait beaucoup de d'amis d'Albanais
mais
c'est changer mon amour c'est pas c'est
pas des amis probablement avant des
en Serbie la foi et la nation font bon
ménage pour les Serbes le Kosovo c'est
le berceau de l'orthodoxie religieuse
là-bas de nombreuses églises ont été
détruites comme celle du village de
prédrague ça c'était son église de son
visage
après en 99 après le départ en fait
alors l'église même à Paris c'est un peu
le dernier refuge reste à brûler un
cierge en espérant une vie possible au
pays
de l'autre côté de Paris mérita notre
étudiante kosovar n'en a pas fini avec
la fête nationale mais là plus question
de protocole les Albanais de tous les
Balkans dont ces boivent à la santé du
Kosovo indépendant
[Musique]
s
si tout va bien mérita sera bientôt
attaché culturelle entre Christina et
Paris ou diplomate serbe et Albanais
sévites ou aucune association d'entente
n'est pas déclaré Paris ou pour certains
comme gentille cet ami Albanais de
mérita un début de réconciliation avec
les Serbes reste possible de toute façon
moi ce que je peux dire c'est que j'ai
beaucoup d'amises à Paris j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de les avoir en Albanie mais
je n'ai pas mal à Paris donc
j'aime bien ça et j'aime bien cette
ville pour ça aussi